[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY KOES: Thank
you all for coming
on one of the later speeches
of the conference today--
super excited to
have you all here.
I'm Mary Koes.
I am a product manager
with Stackdriver Logging.
EDUARDO SILVA: Hi.
My name Eduardo.
I'm a software engineer
at Treasure Data.
MARY KOES: And we're
here to talk to you today
about getting started
running a centralized logging
solution on Google Cloud.
And I have to say nothing
but my deep love of logs
would convince me to
stand up on stage here.
So I'm really excited
to get to share with you
why centralized logs can
make your life easier,
how to do that in Google Cloud.
Eduardo will talk a little bit
about logging in Kubernetes
specifically, and then
some insights from managing
logs of scale that we've had--
we've learned, sometimes the
hard way, through Google.
So let me see just
a show of hands.
Has anyone-- do we have
any current Google Cloud
customers in the audience
who use Stackdriver Logging?
Awesome.
And another show of hands-- do
we have any software engineers
from Google here who use
logging in their day-to-day life
at Google?
Yeah, they don't really
let us into these.
Oh, we have one.
Yay.
A couple.
So they don't usually
let us into these talks,
so that's awesome.
The team that I work
with in Pittsburgh
does both the logs to help
all of our Cloud customers
manage their
operations at scale,
but also the logs that
our Google engineers use
for understanding the
applications we develop
internal to Google as well.
So let's talk about
why logs matter.
Fundamentally,
troubleshooting-- anything,
but especially distributed
microservices is really hard.
So we have, in the cloud, a
bunch of interconnected pieces,
like this puzzle.
And when something
goes wrong, it's
really hard to figure out how we
need to put them back together.
Logs will give us
visibility into our system.
So in the puzzle
analogy, they're
the picture on our
puzzle pieces here.
And while you could
assemble things
one puzzle piece at a time,
a centralized log view
will allow you to see
all of the picture
at the same time,
which will help
you to improve your reliability,
performance, and security.
So let's talk about
how we actually
deliver on a centralized
logging solution running
in Google Cloud.
And I mentioned I am the
product manager for Stackdriver
Logging.
That is one of three
pillars that we
have within
Stackdriver, so we've
got logging, monitoring,
and application performance
management, or APM.
And each of these are
part of a SaaS ops suite
to help all of you monitor and
troubleshoot your applications,
whether they're running
on GCP, AWS, or cloud
native infrastructure,
and trying to keep
your apps fast and available.
So we have a bunch of
different components here.
We have log producers
on the one side,
and there are many
different ways logs come in
that you care about.
So we have audit logs,
which are super special.
We've got platform logs that
are sent from individual Google
services like Cloud
Load Balancer.
We have open source
components that
are creating logs that
you might be running
to power your
infrastructure in your apps,
and then there are logs that
come directly from the apps
themselves.
On the other hand, we've
got consumers of logs.
So there are a number
of different options
for consuming logs.
One, of course, is
Stackdriver Logging.
Some users will also
want to consume logs
in a tool like Google
BigQuery or save them
for compliance in
Google Cloud Storage
or use one of the many
different partner applications
that we support, including Sumo
Logic, Splunk, and Elk Stack,
just to name a few of
the more common ones.
So the log router is what
actually glues these two things
together-- the producers
and the consumers.
So if I look over
here, I've got,
at the top, the log producers.
Everything gets centralized
through the logging API.
And then we've got
the log router,
which will help us to get the
logs to the right endpoint.
And down at the bottom, we
have the Stackdriver product
on the left-hand side, and
then on the right-hand side,
we have other
potential destinations,
whether it's cloud storage,
BigQuery, or anywhere else,
which can go through Pub/Sub.
In order to get logs
into Stackdriver,
there is zero
setup for GCP audit
logs and logs from
GCP services, so any
logs that are being created on
your behalf by a GCP service.
And then if you want to
instrument your code,
you can also use
client libraries
to send logs to
the API directly.
But the vast
majority of our logs
that aren't sent
from cloud services
actually go through our open
source logging agent, Fluentd.
EDUARDO SILVA: Hello.
Maybe most of you already
know what is a logging agent,
but if we go like years
ago, we will say that,
and we can think about logging.
The first thing that we can
think about is maybe syslog.
Have you used syslog before?
Please raise your hand.
So everybody who raised their
hand is over 30, [LAUGHS]
actually.
Yeah.
So logging mechanism exists
for a couple of reasons,
maybe because you
went to troubleshoot,
you want to monitor
something, or understand
what's going on in your
applications in your system.
So what we're talking about
here, logging is not new.
I think that logging
exists from the beginning,
since if you're doing
development, you're debugging.
You have some kind
of logging mechanism.
If you are deploying
your application,
you have some logging
mechanism for that.
It could be through syslog,
rsyslog, or just writing
to a plain log file
in the file system.
But we have current
problems now.
In the past, we used to
have, like, common messages.
The application is doing A,
B, C, D, or it's crashing.
We have some exceptions.
But what happens when you have
multiple applications that
generate data in
a different way?
For example, if you
know Apache web server,
Apache web server creates
their own log entry,
saying this is an
IP address, this
is a practical version
size of the document.
If you look at, for
example, MySQL logs, they
look pretty much different.
What kind of query was running?
What's our reception?
How are the tables?
Do we have some charting
or things like that?
So if you want to
do logging, it's
not because logging is cool.
I think that, honestly,
logging is boring from a--
MARY KOES: It's cool.
EDUARDO SILVA: --from
a play perspective,
but you have to deal with
that, because you have problems
that you need to solve.
So the thing is if you have
multiple source of information
that come from different
places in different formats,
the ultimate goal that you
want to do is data analysis.
So in order to do data analysis,
you need a logging agent,
and this logging agent must
have different strategies
to deal with data
formats, data sources.
One thing is to read log
files from the file system.
The other is to listen
from TCP or UDP.
If you're using, for
example, hardware devices
like firewalls, and they are
sending their logs over UDP,
you need to support that too.
So we are moving forward.
We can think about
many logging agents,
but the experience here is
that Treasure Data, the company
that I work for, we created
Fluentd around seven years ago
to solve the whole data
collection problem.
And Fluentd is an
open source project.
It's fully open
source, and right now,
the CNCF, the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation,
the goal of this project is
it allows you to consume logs
from multiple places
with different formats
and ingest back the information
on any kind of central database
like Google Stackdriver
or your own elastic search
database or MySQL.
In general, as a
project and ecosystem,
we have more than 700 plugins.
And I think that from
a company perspective,
we maintain like 10 or 20.
And all of the others are
made by the community.
Do you know Fluentd?
Is anybody using
Fluentd before here?
Good.
We have some users.
MARY KOES: Awesome.
Thanks.
So once we get logs into
the centralized logging
API, however that
happens, and many times
through our logging
agent, our next goal
is to get it to the
right destination.
And this is where the log
router comes into place.
So we have two kind of
different flows for managing
logs through the log router.
One is called log sinks, and
that is basically an inclusion
filter, so you're going to say
exactly what it is you want
sent to these destinations.
And if you don't say
anything, nothing
will go to these destinations.
We can send the same log
to BigQuery and Pub/Sub
or to none of the above.
On the other side,
we have logs being
sent to Stackdriver,
the logging product
and we manage this
via exclusion filter.
So if you do nothing,
all your logs
will go to Stackdriver logging.
And then if there are certain
logs that you don't want to go
there-- either because you don't
want anyone in your company
to have access to them or if
you don't want to pay for them--
then you can use
an exclusion filter
to control what goes
into Stackdriver logging.
And that's a pretty
big difference
compared to many
of the other cloud
platform logging
experiences out there.
So I'll call out two important
ideas around our log router.
One is that logs can be
exported to log sinks,
even if they are excluded
from Stackdriver log storage.
So this is something
that can be a little bit
tricky to get from our
documentation-- we'll work on
that-- but hopefully, clear now.
And then the other thing
that's a really powerful tool
is a tool called
aggregated exports.
So most of our customers
have an organization
with more than one
project, and they
want to manage logs across
their entire organization.
A special use case here is
security, where oftentimes,
the security team wants
to see the audit logs
across their entire
organization.
And so an aggregated export can
be set up either at the folder
level or at the org level.
And it will inherit all
of the stuff below it,
so if audit logs are created
for a new project that
didn't exist now in
the organization,
we will go ahead and include
those in the export as well.
And then the last
thing I'll talk
about in terms of
logging tools is how you
analyze logs with Stackdriver.
And we'll get to a demo
here in just a moment,
but Stackdriver Logging
supports both basic and advanced
filters.
We also have a tool
called Error Reporting
as part of the logging
library toolkit
here that will automatically
go through your logs and group
like logs together, specifically
looking for stack traces
and issues in your code.
And then we also
provide the ability
to create alerts and
dashboards from logs
by using a tool called
Logs-Based Metrics,
and that pairs with
Stackdriver Monitoring.
So that's kind of
a theme that you'll
hear across the
Stackdriver tools
is that while you can
use logging by itself
or monitoring by
itself or APM tools
by themselves, if you use
multiple ones together,
you can actually get something
that is more powerful than any
of them individually.
And now my favorite
part is demo time.
If we could cut
over here, perfect.
All right, so I have a
web store running on GKE.
And I can see the logs
from my web store.
At first glance, I can see, hey,
there are quite a bit of logs,
looks like a lot of errors.
But I'm not really
sure where to get
started if there's an issue.
So my first stop and first
stop for many customers
is let's check out
Error Reporting
to see if it's automatically
identified anything for us.
And sure enough, having
looked through our logs,
out of all of those errors,
it's identified a specific error
in our application
that someone tried
to set the quantity
to less than zero,
which caused a specific error.
And I can click on that.
I can see exactly how
many customers have
been impacted by this error.
I can see the stack
trace so that I
can tell exactly where in
my code just came from,
and I could go to
Stackdriver Debugging
to investigate further,
if I wanted to, from here.
I can also jump directly back to
the logs to view the raw logs.
I can link to an
issue, so this one here
links to a GitHub
issue, for example.
And I can also track
the resolution status.
So for example, if someone tells
me one of our developers says,
hey, I fixed this error.
It should be all set.
It's deployed.
I can go ahead and say, this
error should be resolved,
and then we say,
OK, no known errors.
That's great.
If I go back to
my catalog here--
and we'll test it to see
if this actually works--
and I add something
to my cart, let's see
what happens if we try
to set the quantity
to a negative number.
We'll update the
basket, and I'll
come back over to
Error Reporting,
and reload it here
for just a moment.
And this usually updates in
about five to 10 seconds,
and we can see that
it automatically
identified that the error had
been seen again and reopened
to the issue.
If I wanted to, I can
also turn on notifications
so that rather than me
going to this dashboard,
it'll proactively push alerts
for new or re-opened errors
to my inbox.
So that's a very
common use case we
hear from a lot
of developers who
are using Stackdriver Logging.
But we hear a number
of other examples
for, like, security use cases.
So something that
I hear a lot is,
I want to be alerted if
anyone adds an email,
let's say from a
Gmail.com domain.
So in the UI, I can
interact with it
in sort of a point
and click mode,
but I can also interact with
the logs in the Advanced Filter,
and then type in more
advanced queries.
So in the case of
identifying something
that comes from a
Gmail.com account,
I need to create a logs-based
metric so that I can then
alert on that.
So I'm going to go over
to my Logs-Based Metrics,
and I've created one here.
I'm going to go ahead
and edit that metric.
For anything that
comes from logs
that are set IAM policy, that
binds a member to @gmail.com,
I want to count all of these.
And that's kind
of the first step.
So I'll be able to have
dashboards about everyone who's
been added from an
@gmail.com account,
and then I can also create
alerting policies on that.
And I can see that earlier
this morning, my Google account
did add somebody
who was @gmail.com.
So let me go back to
our logs-based metrics
and go ahead and show
you how you would create
an alerting policy on this.
So I'm going to Create
Alert from Metric.
This will pop me over into
Stackdriver Monitoring, which
is where I manage
all of my dashboards
and my alerting policies.
So I'm able to, here, see
the logs-based metric.
Take a look here.
I don't have any
recent ones, but I'm
going to go ahead and create
an alerting policy if I ever
see this, because I don't
ever expect to see this.
And instead of duration, I'm
going to say most recent value.
So if this ever happens,
I want to be alerted.
Go ahead and save the condition,
and create a notification.
So I'll send it to my
favorite email address,
auditlogsrock@gmail.com.
I can add some documentation
in terms of who to contact.
Name this policy.
And I'll go ahead and save it.
So now if I go ahead and add
a new member to an IAM policy
anywhere in this
project, I will receive
a notification about this.
Another common use case
we hear from customers
is that they want to send
their logs someplace else.
So this is the beauty of the
centralized logging solution
is that it all
comes in centrally,
and then we can slice
and dice it and send it
to many different places
using exports, which
is the log router
that we were talking
about just a moment ago.
So I'll start out
with a very common use
case, which is I want to
send all of my audit logs
to BigQuery.
So I select a filter.
In this case, I'm
going to say everything
that matches the activity
audit logs in the log name.
And then I simply select
BigQuery and the destination
and create a sink.
And any future logs that
match this will automatically
be sent to BigQuery,
which is great,
but that only helps
me for this project.
What if I want to do this
at the organization level?
So in this case, I need to
pull up my Cloud Shell here.
And I can use a gcloud
command to set this
at the organizational level.
And I'll call out right here.
We have "include children,"
and we're setting this up
at the organization level.
Same thing, though--
the log name
matches the filter
of anything that
has cloudaudit.googleapis.com.
And I'm going to go
ahead and save this,
and now any audit
logs from anywhere
in my organization will
all go to the same BigQuery
destination.
Now one tricky thing
just to remember
is now that I set it
up at the org level,
any audit logs that
come from this project
will be written twice.
So in that case,
I'd probably want
to go back and get rid of
the one at the project level.
Another thing that
we have users do
a lot is I want to act on logs.
So in this case, let's say
every time a new VM is spun up,
I want to take a look
at it, process it
with Cloud Functions,
maybe, and add some labels
or apply some rules to it.
So I'm going to create
a sink for any time
that I have created an instance,
which is the insert command.
And I'll be able to send
all of these to Pub/Sub.
I can then use a Cloud Function
to pull all of the logs
from Pub/Sub, process them, take
whatever action I want on them.
So this is another
common use case we see.
And then last but
not least, we'll
talk about log exclusions.
So we have a page
dedicated to helping
you understand what
your log volume is
across your various Google
Cloud resources or AWS resources
here as well.
And I can see, for example,
taking a look here,
a lot of my volume
in this project
is coming from Kubernetes, so
that's the bulk of my logs.
I can see, though,
that projected
through the end of the month
is 43 gigabytes, which is well
within the free limit
of 50 gigabytes,
so I'm not too, too worried.
But I could go ahead
and say, you know what?
I'm going to send these
logs maybe to my Elk Stack.
I don't want to pay for
them in Stackdriver.
I could go ahead and disable
the logs altogether here,
or I could create an
exclusion filter based
on this and, for example,
say, anything that is less
than a warning level, I want to
maybe just sample those logs.
So instead of
excluding 100% of them,
maybe I will set this is 99%.
I can also deep dive into the
logs volume in Stackdriver
Monitoring using the
Metrics Explorer tool
and visualize exactly where my
volume of logs is coming from.
And if we could cut back please
to the presentation, awesome.
EDUARDO SILVA: So now with
a solution like Stackdriver,
we can say that logging
is not long and boring.
But before that, handling
logs in the different formats,
many sources, and correlate
data is quite hard.
And I'm sure if you are working
already with distributed system
or cluster or with
Kubernetes, there's
quite challenges that
needs to be solved.
So what I'm going
to explain now is
about how logging operates
at Kubernetes level.
So if you understand
the problem, how
it works behind
the scenes, means
you can optimize
the engine queries
and get better insights
from your data.
Do we have any
Kubernetes users here?
Oh, good.
So I'm going to do a
little introduction
about how logging
works in Kubernetes
or when you play with
docking containers.
And basically, you
have one application
that triggers a message,
and that message
means to be like a log message
saying a status, an alert,
a warning, or anything related.
For example, we have,
like, "Hey Next."
But it's not just
about the message.
That message has some metadata
that needs to be correlated.
One of them is at what time
this message was generated,
and the other is what's the
channel that this message was
generated from.
If we speak about
containers, there
are two main channels, standard
output, standard error.
And here, for example, "Hey
Next" is just not a next.
We have JSON example
with metadata.
That message then needs
to be stored somewhere.
There are many ways to
store container logs
or in Kubernetes logs, if,
for example, we have systemd.
But here we are going to
refer how Docker operates.
Basically, your message is
stored in the file system,
in a pod.
So every message
becomes a new JSON map,
and every message is appended
at the end of that file.
But things will become a
little bit complex later,
because if we think
about how Kubernetes
works from an
architectural perspective,
we can think about this.
You have your application,
the most simple use case.
That application is
running in a container.
Container appends
limitation restrictions
and allows you to set
up certain policy rules
and also how this
process that is running
can communicate with others.
And when I say the
"container," you
know that container is
just a concept, right?
From an operating
system perspective,
it's all about
namespaces and cgroups.
So your application
runs in a container,
and that container runs in a
concept, which is called a pod.
So things get
complex, because a pod
can have multiple containers.
Multiple pods can be
running on the same node.
And a node I'm referring
to to a bare metal
machine or a BPEL machine.
So here is just one single
machine, but in a real cluster,
you have many of them.
So imagine that you have
your distributed application.
You told Kubernetes, please
deploy my application.
Kubernetes, based on
the scaling policies,
is going to decide where
these containers will run
or will scale up.
It's going to create
some replicas on which
node these replicas will run.
And likely, not all of them
will run in the same node.
So these become complex.
If I tell you 20
years ago, please
look at my logs from
my application, well,
you open the terminal.
You do some SSH and look what's
going on with your application.
Just cut, file, and
you get the message.
But on this, if you
have a huge cluster,
you cannot do an SSH on every
node and try to find which is
the local JSON file that belongs
to the application that I just
deployed, but maybe that
application will destroy it,
because it failed
or it was scaled up.
So things become more
complex, and complex
because we need to create or
try to gather some context
and what we refer with context,
because your application is
running in a pod.
That pod has a name.
That pod has an ID,
an identification.
Also, you're running
in a namespace.
If you deploy a pod, that
pod belongs to a namespace.
It's running in a
node, in a host.
Maybe you added some labels
and annotation to the pod,
because maybe an
annotation say, no--
this-- for example--
sorry.
Some labels saying,
OK, [INAUDIBLE]
running or belongs to
production, quality, testing,
or anything like that.
So how do you create
all this context
for an application which
is running in Kubernetes?
This whole context also
[INAUDIBLE] more complexity.
And it's because this.
Because the container
name and the container ID,
you can find it in
the file system.
And I'm talking here
about the very low level
how things operate.
You can get that.
But all of the other components
come from the Kubernetes API
server or the master server.
So you have some
information that is locally
in the node and other
information that's
in a separate machine.
And you need that
your logging agent
be able to get all of
this information together.
And that's why the logging
agent that you use and that
Stackdriver use needs to be able
to handle all of this for you,
because of course, you
cannot do this manually.
But your logging agent needs
to be able to create a file
system, understand the
messages, parse the messages--
which are in different formats--
and correlate all the
information together
with context coming
from the API server.
And that's Fluentd.
Actually, Stackdriver
uses Fluentd.
You will find it
as Google Fluentd,
because it's a
Fluentd package that's
ready to use with
Google services, which
has the whole extensions
and integration
with the Stackdriver
right out of the box.
And once you get the things
of Fluent as a log processor,
you can send things to
Stackdriver or maybe
your own database.
Maybe you're running on prem,
or you have your own system
to store logs.
So that's why the
logging agents--
it's not easy to be a
logging agent as a tool,
and also needs to be
able and communicate
with different components
over the network.
Now log processing in Kubernetes
is like the next step.
If we think that we
have just a single node,
well, we'll have the
master and a single node.
Fluentd, as a logging agent,
needs to run as a DaemonSet.
Do you know what a DaemonSet is?
Are you familiar with pods?
We just spoke about.
OK.
A DaemonSet-- it's like
a pod, but this pod
runs on every node
of the cluster.
So if you append more nodes
to your Kubernetes cluster,
like a [INAUDIBLE] machine,
and you already deploy it,
a DaemonSet, you're going to get
a new pod with that DaemonSet
running on that new node.
So the way to work is that you
deploy Fluentd as a DaemonSet.
Of course,
[INAUDIBLE] is already
working by default. What
it does, it's running,
and it starts reading the whole
log files that we explained
a few slides ago, and
all the content and JSON
files that were created.
Once it read the whole
content from the application,
it makes sure to gather
the metadata that
agitate every message,
with every container,
with every port, with labels,
annotations, and so on.
So the simple message that
we started at the beginning
becomes something like
this with context.
Because it has Kubernetes, it
has a host, pod name, pod ID,
container, name,
namespace, and so on,
because then in a Stackdriver or
any database that you're using,
you don't want to query a
show me the message that start
with "Hey Next."
You want to say, show me
all the messages that,
for example, that the
container name, so
Kubernetes, that container
name, equal "next."
So this metadata allows you
to do a better data analysis
and help the storage solution to
create the data that you really
care about it and not
query all of them.
MARY KOES: Thanks.
So I mentioned earlier that
we have the same team that
supports both our Cloud
Logging solution and Google's
internal logging solution.
So we've learned
a lot of lessons
talking to customers like
yourselves and customers
at Google--
who use the logging
tools that we build.
So I wanted to share
some lessons learned.
One is the value
of structured logs,
so not all logs
are created equal.
They all have great potential,
but if we format them
in a specific way, we're able
to answer questions more easily.
So an unstructured
log might have
a text payload of blah, blah,
blah, purchased four widgets.
A structured log will
have a lot of key value
pairs in JSON format.
This makes it much easier,
then, to answer questions like,
how many unique customers
purchased a widget?
How many widgets were
purchased overall?
If you use structured
logs, you can then send--
when you, for example,
send stuff to BigQuery,
that structure will
persist and make
it much easier to interact with
your logs downstream as well.
Plus, you can do things in
Stackdriver logging like say,
show me the customer ID hash.
I want that to be
displayed easily,
so I can understand what's
going on more quickly.
The other tip that we have
learned over the years
is that it can be
really tricky to get
the right level of logging.
If you do too much,
it's crazy expensive,
and you can't find
anything in your logs.
If you do too little, then
you don't have the data
that you need when you need it.
And so trying to get that
just right level of logs
can be a real challenge
both internal to Google
and for our customers.
There's no magic bullet
here, but one thing
we found to be really
helpful is to enforce
a consistent definition
for logging levels
through your code.
So an error should be something
that really stopped your code,
and you expect somebody to
actually investigate here,
whereas maybe debug and
info are less important.
And that makes it
easier, when I filter,
to quickly find the
information that we care about.
And the final kind of insight
we've derived over time
is that it's really helpful to
have data about the log volume
so that you can iterate
and refine this over time.
So specifically, in
Stackdriver Logging,
we have metrics at a
very fine-grained level,
so you can see not only which
resources are sending logs,
but which logs or which--
are you getting mostly errors,
or are these mostly info
statements?
And you can slice
and dice your data
in all sorts of
ways, which can allow
you to iterate on your
logging solution over time.
EDUARDO SILVA: So getting
back to logging agents,
there are many solutions and
open source products available.
But when talking
specifically about Fluentd,
which is the default agent
in Stackdriver and also
for [INAUDIBLE]
companies and products,
we can think that
Fluentd is more than just
a simple open source project.
I would like to say that
it is a whole ecosystem.
Since the moment there are many
companies contributing back
to the same project
means that it's
more relevant for the
market, and also, it's
becoming a huge solution.
And at some point, people said
that Fluentd for some cases
was too heavy, or we have
some performance issues.
And sometimes the question
is, how many records are you
ingesting per second?
Sometimes they say, a
few thousands per second.
Of course, you're going to have
some performance penalties.
You need memory, CPU, and
you are filtering data,
and you have like 10 filters,
that is time-consuming.
And they said, OK, but we
need something lightweight.
Fluentd original is
written in Ruby and C.
It's quite performant,
but at high scales,
some companies
and user customers
said we need something that
can be lightweight and more
tied to cloud native solutions.
And that's why we created
a second project, which
is called Fluentbit, created
same by Treasure Data, now
driven by the community.
It's also with the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation,
and Fluentbit tried to solve
the problems in the cloud native
space in a different way.
You've seen the same background
or experience from Fluentd.
This is not like a
replacement for Fluentd,
but most of cases, people
said, I want to use Fluentd.
And for this special
namespace class,
I'm going to run Fluentbit
because of performance
reason or special features.
The good thing about
Fluentbit is that it's
written in Perl and C language.
It's optimized for performance,
low memory footprint.
And it also has a
pluggable architecture.
It's pretty much a Fluentd,
but Fluentd ecosystem
is quite huge.
We have 700 plug-ins.
Here, we have like 45.
So you can see that it's more
tied for specific things,
and it's fully integrated with
Kubernetes and Prometheus,
and it's a sub-project
of the CNCF.
And like a kind of
announcement, we
are releasing in a couple of
days the new version, which
is called 0.14.
I think that sometimes numbers
does not mean something.
The [INAUDIBLE] been around
for more than three years,
but we're trying to have the
1.0 at the end of the year.
And 0.14 will have integration
with Google Stackdriver.
It will not, at the
beginning, this integration
is quite experimental.
It means that it doesn't
have the whole features
that Google Fluentd has,
but we're working on that.
Also, we will have the load
balancing capabilities.
In logging, there is
one specific feature
that if you are dispatching
your logs to your service,
and you have some
[INAUDIBLE] audit,
your logging agent needs
to be able to recover
from that situation
meaning doing buffering
or maybe trying, if
it fell from point A,
try to do some
balancing, and try
point B or a different node.
So that balancing capability
is coming up right now,
and also, we're
happy to say that we
are implementing a new way to
do filtering in a logging agent.
If you wanted to do some
filtering of Fluentd,
you had to write your own
Ruby script for filtering.
But if you wanted to do it
on Fluentbit, like few weeks
ago, you had to
write your C filter.
And for some people
said, I cannot write C.
It's too complex, and I don't
have the time, which is right.
We went in Europe at the
beginning of this year in QCon,
and some people say,
hey, GDPR is coming.
And I was not aware about GDPR.
OK, what is GDPR?
Explain it to me more about it.
And they said, OK, we
need to obfuscate data.
We need to add some conditionals
for the configuration
for Fluentbit and fix like A, B,
C, D. OK, that is too complex.
We cannot maintain multiple
plugins for different needs.
Yeah, because they said our logs
are credit card transactions,
and they have the
whole numbers, and we
need to obfuscate the data.
So we need a solution.
That is important.
So we said, OK, a new way
to do filtering will be,
let's try to do some scripting.
You run Fluentbit as an agent,
but also, when it starts,
you can start your own scripts,
reading in Lua language, which
are quite performant.
And you can do all
the data modifications
that you want without
low performance penalty.
And also, we have
an address here.
If you want to get more about
all the news on Fluentbit 0.14
to be released, there's a
link on the slides that you--
a form where you can
sign up to get the news.
And we're taking
the Lua script--
this is like a simple plugin.
Well, this is like a text file.
This is Lua, where
basically, you
create a new record
using Lua tables,
where you can put the
old content in one index
and the new content
in a new key,
and just work on those values.
Fluentbit will be
able to understand
that this modification
was requested from Lua,
and it will modify
your records for you,
so you don't need to create
a new filter for Fluentbit,
and just write your
own Lua scripts.
So Fluentbit quite
exciting project.
Actually, we get, like,
from a Docker and Kubernetes
perspective, we get like 50,000
[INAUDIBLE] a day and growing,
which is a lot, so we expect
to reach a huge millions
at the end of the year.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]